so there's now a discussion happening
about how soon joe biden and democrats
should wait
for republicans to negotiate on the
coveted relief bill
before just going forward and passing it
without republican support via budget
reconciliation
if democrats have the votes in the
senate now there are people
criticizing joe biden why is joe biden
meeting with republicans about the
coveted bill why is joe biden inviting
10 democrat
10 republican senators to meet as he did
last night
when these people are clearly bad faith
actors there's not going to be unity
there's not going to be negotiation that
gets us anything close to what joe biden
wants which is a 1.9 trillion dollar
package
and i basically agree with all of that
other than to say
the meeting is fine let's just
understand that after the meeting
republicans as we've already seen them
do this morning
are going to insist that they want some
pathetic 600 billion dollar
stimulus bill these same senators who
now are going back
to the tired old tropes of republicans
we can't afford it
but where's the money going to come from
but inflation
but the debt but the deficit people who
said nothing as trump
exploded the deficit despite claiming he
would pay off the entire national debt
during his first term these same
republican senators
gleefully happily voted for 740 billion
dollars for the military budget
just recently so they are hypocrites
they are exactly uh who we believe them
to be
they are going to obstruct and get in
the way and blah blah blah blah blah joe
biden's proposal is for 1.9 trillion
dollars
these republicans want 618 billion
and they met yesterday uh with joe biden
so
i think that the meeting with them is
fine as long as joe biden and democrats
are ready to say
listen remember they promised two
thousand dollar checks would go out
right away it's february now right away
we could debate
what right away means in government
speak but joe biden definitely made us
think jon ossoff definitely made us
think
that the checks were going out quickly
it's been a couple weeks almost now okay
so
it's time to do it have the meeting with
the republicans but understand that
republicans are going to make all sorts
of demands
they are going to demand capitulation to
their ideology
to their platform they will weaken the
bill they will weaken the impact of the
bill
and ultimately even if you come up with
something that's between
600 billion and 1.9 trillion they'll
probably
still refuse to vote for it anyway okay
these are not good faith actors so don't
be
mad that joe biden is meeting with
republicans i'm fine with it
it's fine that he's doing it he claimed
he wants bipartisanship and unity and
all this stuff
that's fine they were able to propose
their 600 billion dollar package
and they are likely to vote against
whatever compromise democrats end up
proposing so
my view is given the meeting and then
pass 1.9 trillion without a single
republican if that's what they want to
do now you need
joe if you don't get a single republican
you need joe manchin's vote and we need
to be sure
that joe manchin is going to vote for it
republicans will shriek
they will demand that they be met
halfway they will say what about unity
what about bipartisanship blah blah blah
but when it's democrats asking
republicans
to meet them halfway when trump is in
power
remember what republicans said well
elections have consequences
we're not going to just because you guys
want this different thing
trump won and we control this and we
control that so
democrats should have a spine and be
ready because
for an issue to have a compromise both
sides have to concede things to make
that work
the republican party is not offering to
concede anything
the democratic proposal is 1.9 trillion
and it's popular with the american
people
republicans are just saying no is the
concession that they will grant
any money because remember many
republican voters want the stimulus
package as well
this is not a stimulus package that is
only popular with democratic voters
republicans are not conceding anything
they are negotiating when they don't
actually have leverage
if joe biden and democrats are actually
ready and willing to pass this
without a single republican vote so my
suggestion is
ignore the bad faith whining of
republicans
democrats are passing popular bills that
60
70 80 of americans support
uh the executive order on masking from
joe biden
and you can't you know we talk about we
don't want to stoop to their level
we don't want to do what they do listen
we're not obstructing anything
joe biden won democrats controlled the
house democrats took the senate
voters including independents democrats
but also
republicans want the stimulus so just
pass it
you gave them their meeting it's time to
pass it you promised you would do it
and i hope that they actually do this
could be the first major success of the
biden administration
and it will show that it's joe biden who
will set the agenda
and democrats not mitch mcconnell or
this will be the first major failure for
joe biden and it will be a big failure
when you say if i win and ossoff and
warnock win 2 000 checks are going out
right away
and we get into february 10th
mid-february late february and you still
don't have anything past or you end up
passing something that's pathetic and
paltry
that's not going to look good so it's
time to get it together
let's uh as we like to say put on our
big boy pants
and get this thing done these people
these republicans are not your friends
they're not going to help you they're
not looking to compromise they're
looking to get in your way
you've got to go around them on this
important issue most healthy granola
bars have sort of a bad reputation they
don't taste good
they don't fill you up they don't really
satisfy your craving
but our sponsor monk pack has changed
granola bars monk pack keto granola bars
are sweet and delicious
soft and chewy with only 140 calories
1 gram of sugar 2 net carbs which makes
them work beautifully
for the keto or low carb lifestyles
they come in flavors like coconut cocoa
chip
honey nut blueberry almond vanilla my
new favorite
i love these because i can grab one
anytime
it's quick it's a great snack forget the
dry
bland granola bars try monk pack
keto granola bars if you don't love them
like i do
they'll give you all of your money back
you'll get 20
off when you go to monkpack.com and use
the coupon code
pacman the link is underneath this video